Jaakko echo how do you work with people
who overthink things the classic
over-thinker what does that mean the
over it means they won't pick up this
pen right here because they look at and
say hmmm I wonder what the way to that
pen is and if I should pick it up right
now because I'm also thinking about
saying something and what if I dropped
the pen awhile I'm trying to say
something that makes a noise on the desk
that disrupts from the flow of my
sentence and then the whole flow of my
sentence is disrupted which means my
train of thought will be disrupted now I
can't we finish what I was gonna say
that's an over-thinker
so that's personal now you can just
imagine applying that thought pattern to
an actual project that you're working on
right not a good scenario or you're
trying to apply it to a combat situation
that you're in or you're trying to apply
it to a relationship that you're in you
start over thinking well if I say this
then she might think that right what
they mean by that right there that
little look that's an over-thinker my so
quit thinking so much you're
overthinking it so here's what I do when
someone's overthinking when I got
someone that's like a like a Quranic
over thinker I'm gonna I'm gonna funnel
them into the right mindset with
questions and I'll give you some real
easy questions to ask that'll make this
happen things like hey we mean by that
mm-hmm or like can you explain that
again and you're getting them to explain
it in a simpler way mm-hmm or you say
you know hey so hold on so what's the
actual goal what are we trying to get
done here because again they're putting
layers upon layers of complexity on top
of things that don't deserve it
so what exactly are we trying to do
mm-hmm
and again you're just kind of playing
dumb a little bit and asking questions
and then if you can't get to them if you
can't quite get them to simplify it then
you say oh oh okay so we're trying to do
this very simple statement so that way
they start subconsciously being coached
and being taught to simplify things as
much as they can in their head
and you know another thing I've been
saying lately when I'm out working with
people is I used to not really
understand why people are drawn to this
complexity but I actually think I
understand now and I think it has
something to do with the fact that if I
come up with a plan and it's super
complex and super crazy and you don't
understand it then I must be smarter
than you right yeah right I came up with
something that's so genius and so
complicated that you don't even
understand it right I understand it I
understand it yeah it's you don't mean
it right right and by the way you know
the only way you're gonna understand it
if I if is if I break it down for you
because you don't get it you know so
it's an ego trip and it's completely
wrong because the fact of the matter is
if I'm trying to get you to do something
and you don't understand it I'm a loser
I'm failing as a leader so you you you
got to try and get people to understand
that simplicity beats complexity every
single time and overthinking things
is a failure in ability to simplify so
another thing and this is more kind of
about planning and this is something I
used to talk about in the SEAL Teams and
I called it six percent advantage over
the enemy and what this was was let's
say you have a target building that
you're going off of or going after you
gonna go take down a target building in
the middle of wherever in the middle of
the desert and you basically come up
with a plan that you're gonna use your
standard operating procedures you're all
gonna get online or you're gonna at
least set up a base in a maneuver
element it's very simple two elements
one element is gonna hold cover and the
other one's gonna move through the
target cover move it's um it's as simple
as it gets
that's great so you come up with a plan
that's your plan and then as you're
looking at the imagery or you're looking
at the the map you notice that there is
an outhouse mm-hmm 150 meters away from
the house so now what you do is you go
you know what because there's that
outhouse there you know I'm gonna do is
I'm going to take us another team of our
guys we're gonna break
from the main assault force we're gonna
put them over there and that's what
they're gonna be in case the guys in the
outhouse bah-bah-bah so what you've done
is you've separated your units you've
increased your communication problems
you've sacrificed your fields of fire
you disaggregated your firepower you've
diminished your unity of command
you've broke from your standard
operating procedures you've given up
your real tactical advantage that you
have for the chance the chance that this
guy at 2 o'clock in the morning when you
hit the target is in the outhouse and
not in his home hmm is it worth that no
so don't overthink it
we're hitting this target you know what
cool keep eyes on that thing no big deal
but don't give up your tactical
advantage because you overthought the
situation mmm go with what you know and
another piece of that is a lot of times
when people get super detailed like that
and planning they're actually planning
things planning on things that that
can't be known mm-hmm so why would we
make a plan for something that can't be
known I got a better idea instead of
making a plan for something that can't
be known make a plan that's adaptable
mm-hmm you want your plan to be
adaptable and you know how you have the
best adaptability for instance on the
battlefield that you have the most
control over your guys so that you can
move them maneuver them quickly and how
do you do that by having good unity of
command and how do you do that by
keeping you guys for the most part
together hmm the minute you start
spreading them out all over the place
and something changes something unknown
that unexpected happens now you got a
real everyone back in and try and get
them to change the formation of their
assault it becomes very very complex so
if you set up your plan so that it's
adaptable to changing situations then
you're gonna be good to go same thing in
do you know what the markets gonna do
know we have predictors yes do we know
them no do you know what your
competitors gonna do no mm-hmm do you
know what your consumers are gonna do no
do we have intelligence of course we do
do we have metrics of course we do but
we don't know things so keep your plans
adaptable so you can make adjustments
when you need to as opposed to
overthinking things and creating
specific branch plans for a possibility
of something that might occur in the
future or might not mmm don't overthink
it people you know sometimes people who
under think things mm-hmm sometimes they
tend to say hey why you overthink things
when you're when you're just normally
thinking about something like you're
thinking about so there's obviously you
have to think about things right and yes
you should be caution of someone
cautious of someone that's just fun
constantly saying well you're
overthinking this right I spent three
minutes planning yeah yeah watch out for
that guy yeah that's what yeah when the
word open one overthinking comes up I
understand what that means but I feel
like your example is sound